au siècle dernier cette noble demeure
était celle du baron gérard nous sommes
au château de ma race à grenade dont le
bas adour une demeure une petite fille
d'alors a bien connu ses grands-parents
ses parents étaient fermiers germaine
mancier à 75 ans les hasards et les
bonheurs de la vie à ramen amara serait
43 ans d'exil elle a parcouru et
sillonner le monde mais le noël de son
enfance 7 et hier
chez desseilles dans les gens les plus
simples c'était ladhof
et pourquoi l'ado va c'était d'abord un
plat de cette puisque ont acheté la
viande chez le boucher
alors que tout le reste de l'année on se
contentait des choses qu'on avait été
levé soi même à la ferme puisque chacun
élevé un cochon des oies des canards
ensuite il y avait toujours des poulets
mais vraiment chez le boucher uni allait
très très rarement pour faire une daube
il faut une pause de boeuf qui paie en
gros charisme de la farine poids grosse
carotte 3 besogneux du jambon maigre sec
de miles des clous de girofle 1 bouquet
garni sel du soir deux bols d'eau et un
bol de 20 20 mais le secret c'est la
cuisson c4 douce et lente et celle ci va
cuire deux jours alors après avoir roulé
les autographes dans la trafic coupé
deux lions en rondelles il faut mettre
le troisième piqué de courir à chennai
et coupez le jambon en petits morceaux
maintenant je vais prendre le 40 que je
vais couper en rondelles pour les mettre
sur le dessus
et maintenant je vais couvrir le dis
tout ça avec du vin et de l'eau un bol
de 20 pour deux hommes dos ceux à qui je
vais le ficeler sur le toupet une autre
fois je le on le faisait avec le papier
que vous donnez le boucher qui était un
papier bien spéciale un peu jaune ont la
tâche est sûre le toupine avec du raphia
du parti a quitté courant à ce moment là
dans les cuisines et quel rôle avez ce
papier ou l'embauché la vague peur de
s'en aller ils restent tous restés tous
les sucres toutes les odeurs et les
saveurs rester à l'intérieur du tout
bling des terres dites moi germaine
c'est un art de vivre qui a complètement
disparu d'après-vous de la soul hélas
c'était autre chose et puis on pouvait
vivre il me semble qu'on vivait mieux
c'est intensive bien loin de nous